world well listen you know we both
travel america right um
do you see the same country when you go
out to the middle of america that you
read about in the media because i don't
no i see people i've not been traveling
the country by car i'm afraid to fly so
um i traveled across the country in a
car to come out here
and i'm always in places talking with
people and you know a lot of the things
we think we when we meet people they're
people but when we view people
stereotypically and we deal with them in
their group and when they sit in their
group they're not like who they are when
you see them in person right
you know
about this afraid to fly
if you smoke a joint
it doesn't help no i wouldn't try it i
don't know no kind of drug would help me
with that i'm so afraid i just right but
you wouldn't know if you sat next to me
i just faked being cool just the whole
time you
i get some music i work on the score i'm
just in here
yes it is you are always cool i don't
think you need a better phobia oh let's
see
but last time you were here we were
talking about how i mean your theory
that the me and i think a lot of people
shared that the media sort of keeps us
fighting amongst each other well it's a
hustle
you know and the hustle is always based
on getting people on the bottom of a
society to think that each one is the
enemy and in our country has been if you
look at the position that poor southern
white was in he's angry at the people
who cannot affect him
and he's out fighting war for those
people and those who don't affect him
slaves he's looking at them and he's mad
at them you need to be mad at who can
affect your financial condition right
yeah
you're talking about the
you sold the
soldiers who fought for general lee in
the confederacy did not really have a
stake in that they were not owners
they're still fighting and they're still
they're still fighting they're people
fighting against
who live in in places where they never
see a mexican anytime they're fighting
to make sure that mexicans don't come
here
and they're fighting for issues that
don't affect them locally then they're
fighting as a group with some group that
they can't even define really a group
called white or group called black and
my brother and i were laughing about can
you imagine if you got people from
vietnam vietnam
japan
china thailand and you put them all
together and called them a group called
yellows
and then you started to talk to them as
if they were going to adhere to your
concept of what they were
and as a nation we have to kind of uh
we have to figure out what space do we
want to be in in terms of our conception
of ourselves we wouldn't be symbiotic
like you and i we're sitting here
talking do i want to fight you or do i
want to come together with you do i want
to share the space and that's really
what jazz is about it's about sharing
space
[Applause]
you know
it's important to realize that you're
sharing space with people who are not
playing with you would play
so sometimes they're playing notes
rhythm section is accompanying you
they're not playing what you would play
but you can't stop in the middle of what
you're playing say don't play this play
what i would play
so the exercise in the music is how can
we use our form
to to address the issue at hand which is
swinging and sounding good as a group
then how can i work with you
in the space and find a way for us to
swing that's why we go back and forth
[Applause]
and it's not all it's not all fun and
games
you know sometimes it can get heated
it's not all it's not all on engage it
can get heated up no no you try to if
you're professional it won't get heated
on stage
but there have been times when people
have come to issues on stage for for us
in our group we have a very uh very
really good balance and we we
acknowledge it
for the last uh 15 or so years we all
say most bands are very dysfunctional
but you're saying because it's so
improvisational sometimes you get pissed
because some guy is going off on
something that certainly wasn't planned
because it couldn't be but you don't
think that that was a great direction to
go in well there's a lot of choice right
and whether there's choice there's
strife yeah and a lot of paradoxical
moments ambiguous moments and somebody
steps into the space and you have to
make decisions and there are also
hierarchies like the drums or the
president the piano is the legislature
and the base is a judicial branch now
you have to deal with them so
[Applause]
you know
a drama a drama might play something you
don't like then and also the jazz
musicians are very we have heated
personalities like we can speak
good clear english to you
if we don't like what's going on
and we play with a lot of passion and
feeling but we're working out ideas and
things could go in any but there's a
form that you have to know that we
follow you have to agree that you're
trying to swing and that you will follow
that form and you solo as long as you
want so you may solo 15 courses when two
were good
now everybody's looking at you like
so you know you have to want to share
space
can you impeach a drummer
you